the world knows our first guest from a
little show called friends but currently
i just know her as my landlord
i don't consider me a landlord i
consider myself your roommate
ellen degeneres explains why she's
living in courtney cox's house
meanwhile court says filming that
long-awaited friends reunion was so
emotional
[Applause]
on thursday's episode of the ellen
degeneres show the 63 year old tv host
who is married to actress porsha de
rossi
dished on why she's currently crashing
at her famous friend's pad
i'm not having marital troubles i'm not
out of my house because i'm
i'm not living with courtney cox because
i'm kicked out of my house so i'm i'm
we sold our house here in beverly hills
and i needed a place to stay and you
were kind enough to to say yes
stay at my house and while the 56 year
old friend star was happy to help out
her pal
she admitted there have been a few bumps
in the road
you're my style guru so i was nervous
about you staying there
being that i haven't redone it or it's
just i haven't been there in a year so i
had it cleaned and i
moved everything off the right side of
the bathroom so you have your space in
the drawers and
and i was just really ready for you and
all of a sudden i was like wait a minute
evelyn's toothbrush is on my side so
essentially you're a terrible roommate
you took over my side and yourself
no that was porsha who took over your
side roommate issues aside
courtney also dished that the highly
anticipated friends reunion special for
hbo max
has finally been filmed it was
unbelievable
so emotional um it's you know it's
it's an unscripted reunion but we got to
be on stage 24 for the first time
all of us in like i forgot how many
years
15 years or 17 years and you know those
famous opening credits
we were in that fountain for a long time
it uh i don't know who somebody thought
that would just be really fun
and let me tell you what happens it's
not fun to be dancing in the fountains
for hours and hours
yeah turns out it wasn't as joyful as it
looked i remember matthew perry saying
at one point and it didn't we didn't we
didn't
know each other that well at that point
but i remember and this is so matthew
but he was like
i can't remember a time that it wasn't
in this fountain the special was
initially supposed to premiere with the
launch of hbo max on may 27
2020 but had to be pushed back due to
the pandemic
after the reunion was postponed friends
co-creator marta kaufman told et
she wanted to wait to tape the special
until a live studio audience could be
part of the experience
we all want it to happen where we just
have to wait until it's safe i mean this
is a show
it is not scripted um but this is
the way this show works we're going to
need a live audience need a live
audience
even if we socially distance that live
audience it really is a huge part
of what friends has been